[Music]
what else is going on in your life I'm a
pretty simple man a little thing will
put me in a good mood for about a
workweek five days oh yeah little things
will catch me just right I was traveling
from New York recently and on my way
through airport security I don't know
about you guys but when I fly I love
wearing a t-shirt that I don't care
about I actually know very little about
you guys but when I fly always wear a
shirt that I don't care about coz when I
fly I get really sweaty I don't know why
do you sweat when you fly not really
know I'm drenched you get you you sweat
a lot I don't know what it is I'm just
sitting there I get off the plane I got
pit stains my brow is all glistening
people like you've been jogging I'm like
no I'm sitting still in the sky shirt
that I don't care about this is what put
me in a good clean burning mood for five
days I was wearing this shirt that is
soft but I don't like to wear in public
just want to fly sometimes it says dr.
Seuss green eggs and ham
that's the shirt it's an old shirt
you've had just an old shirt you put it
on dr. Seuss green eggs and ham it was a
gift my god I was like they clearly
don't know how cool I am then I got it a
second time and it was like God Himself
being like put on this shirt yeah okay
so I gave you that face please wear the
outside as well so I I don't know if
that's hurtful and I wore that shirt and
I'm going through airport security it's
like 7:30 in the morning I'm a little
bit grumpy I go through that machine
that's killing us all
bathing us in strange rays why do we
agree to that I don't know that's fine
some guy with a bond like a wand and a
radio is like it's fine I'm like okay I
go in I'm grumpy I'm it's like 7:30 in
the morning get out I forget that I'm
wearing this shirt I don't I don't even
see this TSA woman she's in my periphery
and I just hear ago nobody knocks out
of a good mood because I wanna watch you
know cleaning and I forgot that I was
wearing the shirt I didn't know what you
saw I was like is that a security
question Conan I had that stuck in my
head now still more time it just turns
into Tracy Morgan over to new popcorn X
I am Liz Lemon how can you be sad when
that exists oh that what a terrific
thing for you that's what I'm saying
it's a tool for you you can use it if
you're if you're a target which I'm sure
you go to target from time to time yeah
and you're waiting for a parking spot
and then some jerk one of these jerks
you see out there yeah pulls in any
pause Jason I'm against him I'm anti
jerk - yeah takes your parking spot now
you can give up and give in to despair
and the ugliness of the world in just
being rich yeah words yes - the guy yeah
that's a failure he's already unhappy
happy people don't steal spots sure you
can confuse him
roll down the window and look right at
him I mean right at him like a college
freshman playing hey there Delila on the
acoustic just through them
right yeah and when you lock on just go
[Applause]
it's a joy in the car that's a victory
for life out for team have been every
time in that situation is what I'm
saying it's up to us